gorgeous how are you you the how are you
thank you you look beautiful
who are you wearing tonight here at the
critics tree this is Calvin Klein you've
served us with look after look how much
thought and time goes into each one for
a word you know it's always different
you know sometimes it's wonderful when
you get to work with designers and they
make custom looks for you and other
times there's beautiful Couture that's
been created and you just you put it on
and and it's it's wonderful and I feel
so blessed that I get sent such
beautiful things to and you've given us
viral moments Kaka did you see that your
answer about our Judy Garland dress went
viral people were using it to explain
all the thoughts in their head yeah it
was so fun it's so interesting because
we hadn't thought about it but then
looking at the dress and looking at the
photos side by side it really it was an
emulsion but by accident how are you
balancing at all a casual Vegas
residency with award season campaigning
oh my god you know it's a lot of hard
work but I have a wonderful team and we
love what we do and it's it's been
amazing I get to celebrate you know the
art of so many of my peers and then I
also get to sing my pop show in Vegas
and then I have a jazz show as well
which I love I love to sing jazz so I'm
enjoying it so we're asking everyone for
Valentine's Day how did you and your
lovely man first me
that's the secret that's your news sorry
[Music]